i'm not someone who's had sex i'm not
someone who masturbates those are just
not things that
are interesting to me they're not things
i've ever had a desire to
do
[Music]
i remember once in maybe year five or
year six my friends were talking about
like oh which boys do you have a crush
on and i was like
i don't really have a crush on any of
them i mean
this one's nice to me so i guess i like
him and that was kind of how i how i
looked at it i didn't ever feel
like a crush or like an excitement to be
around any of these boys but i was like
well this boy is nice to me that must
mean i like him and i have a crush on
him but that was just someone being nice
to me and
i look back at that and i i really
picked that up as a an early sign of
my asexuality because i just didn't
experience
these childhood crushes in the same way
that everyone else used to
there were times where
like you have your little like teenage
relationships i didn't really have
any really i had one where i was like
kind of close to a guy and people were
like oh have you kissed yet and i was
like
no
i don't want to why would i want to
and that's when i first heard the word
frigid i heard that same girl who
asked me at the very beginning of year
seven oh what boys do you like she was
like oh you're you're just frigid and i
was like i don't know what that even
means um
and
now i look back and i'm like well it's
just something i don't want to do do you
feel different when people were talking
about their their own experiences
i did feel different i
felt like
everyone kind of knew something that i
didn't when i went to college and like
sixth form that was when i really felt
different because that was when everyone
was
exploring
everything they were exploring getting
drunk for the first time exploring like
having first times
different genders stuff like that
different identities as well
that was when i first really felt
different
can you describe exactly what asexuality
is and means
asexuality is defined as not
experiencing sexual attraction uh that
just means that that's not a part of my
brain that clicks in the same way it
does for everyone else
some asexual people can still have sex
some don't some don't mind if it makes
their partner happy and it's something
they want to do then that makes them
happy as well
for me sex is just
not my kind of thing i think it's a
little bit icky but asexuality is just
not experiencing sexual attraction
have you had sex before yourself i have
not had sex no
i'm not someone who's had sex i'm not
someone who masturbates those are just
not things that
are interesting to me they're not things
i've ever had a desire to
do
i just kind of
forget they exist sometimes
so how do how do you feel towards saxon
on the whole i
i don't get it it just feels icky why do
you want to like
do that
that's how i feel when i uh
when i kind of think about it i'm
not completely closed off to the concept
of having sex in the future if i was
very comfortable with a romantic partner
but i feel like i know on a fundamental
level that i would not enjoy it and if i
tried it once that would be the only
time i ever had sex because i just feel
like it's not something i would enjoy
not all asexual people identify as
aromantic so for example myself i
identify as asexual and biromantic which
means i experience romantic attraction
to
two or more genders in a film like a
rom-com or something like in love
actually you've got all of the the cute
little date stuff the dancing at a party
the
holding hands there may be like a little
peck on her cheek stuff like that that
is like the romantic attraction and then
as soon as they go back to the person's
flat and it starts to get like more
intense that's the sexual attraction i
like the first bit i like the the dates
and the holding hands and just the
romantic intimacy but not the sexual
stuff that's how i've always described
the distinction between the two
have you been in romantic relationships
before then i've dated i've not been in
any romantic relationships but i have
dated i've dated
a little bit a couple of years ago but
i don't experience romantic attraction
very often so it takes me a while to
kind of get that that butterfly feeling
so i've only
dated a little bit
so it was your friend that you um
came out to first
me and a couple of her friends were they
were talking about their sexuality stuff
like that they were talking about oh i'm
gay i don't really know many other gay
people there was one of our friends
saying oh a lot of people think i'm
straight i'm just like a bit flamboyant
and at this point i was the the resident
straight gal because it hadn't come out
if you don't come out you're straight
apparently that's how it works it just
clicked in my brain it was like oh
there's an option to just not have to
find anyone
and that's that's okay
and i came out to
my best friend at the time maybe a month
after that and that was when i'd like
just started college so it all really
happened when i was like
16. it felt really nice to to mention it
to someone and i think i made a made a
tweet about it maybe a month after that
so
october of 2015
and
i didn't come out to my family for
another couple of years but just knowing
that i could now talk about this stuff
on twitter the endless void just felt
really good that i didn't have to
to hide this
stuff i could ask questions if i wanted
to find other people who felt the same
and it was just
a really freeing feeling what sort of
questions are you asked
i'm often asked questions like how do
you know you haven't met the right
person how do you know if you haven't
tried it
how
do you know that
you've not just had bad sex in the past
stuff like that
or sometimes people say that oh you're
just
identifying that way because you've had
some kind of sexual trauma in your past
which
is not the case i'm lucky enough to have
not
dealt with something like that and that
has not affected how i identify as an
asexual and then you get comments just
saying oh it's a phase you know you'll
grow out of it you're just a late
bloomer
i hate being told that i haven't met the
right person yet because
you have so many people who are in
relationships that are just the wrong
relationships for them and they don't
have to be waiting for the right person
to know that they enjoy sex
can you tell us about what you do to
help
educate others on asexuality
i talk about asexuality on my youtube
channel and
often
on interviews and panels
in lgbtq plus spaces or at universities
i basically just try and make the
content that i would have wanted to
watch when i was coming out there was
content on asexuality on youtube when i
was coming out when i was 16 but
but there's there's definitely been a
gap and i hope it's a gap that i have i
have filled but
i just try and talk about asexuality
as it is i try and represent
my experience but also
hopefully give light to other people's
experiences as well and
the kind of comments that i get on
youtube are the exact kind of comments
that i left when i was coming out as
asexual the this is how i feel this is
so nice to see someone else put it into
words
that's what i that's what i try and do
i think just by being so
openly proud about my sexuality and open
to answering questions i've helped
friends and people i don't know as well
just learn more about their sexuality
and be more proud of themselves or at
least that's what they have they have
told me and
it's something that i i'd love to
continue to do
i knew when pe or something was gonna
come up i knew that you know uh the
girls were gonna start you know i wasn't
allowed to get changed with them in
their changing room or anything um
because even though like i say clitoris
i say that loosely uh my clitoris is
basically like a
small dick